[Music]
along yorkshire's High Cliffs seabirds
are back in huge numbers for the nesting
season and conservationists are on high
alert for any sign the bird flu has
returned with them they look to be okay
but that group there would be the ones I
would concentrate on the virus caused
Mass mortality last summer with species
such as gannets devastated as it swept
through crowded colonies The rspb's
Reserve at Benton Cliffs was badly
affected probably 80 percent of the
chicks in these two densest areas died
and we presume that's because one or
both of the adults had died and then
there's unanswered questions were some
birds
sick then recovering and you know will
they come back this year so this year
there's a lot of uh
you know worry about what's going to
anything
until two years ago the h5n1 virus was
mainly a problem in the Autumn as
migratory Ducks geese and swans spread
it to poultry but a new strain is so
infectious that it swept the globe
spread to new wild bird species and is
no longer just a seasonal disease it's
mutating to crossing over to infect
mammals some in the UK along the coast
there's been a small number of seals
known to have died with the virus almost
certainly as a result of eating infected
birds at this time of year they too come
ashore to have their young and a virus
with the right mutations could spread
from mammal to mammal government
scientists say there's no evidence yet
that the virus is spreading between
mammals in the UK but it has happened
abroad and they're carefully monitoring
samples from dead animals for anything
that might signal a raised risk perhaps
even to humans what we're tracking is
we've seen some changes consistently in
the virus that are rarely observed in
bird populations so they're likely to
signal that the virus is making some
adjustment but one adjustment alone will
not be enough for that virus to then
successfully transmit from one mammal to
another a numbers game is a factor the
more exposures you get the more risk
that these events might spark and
Trigger something that can then transmit
which is why we're doing the
surveillance the sudden spread of the
virus in the UK's seabirds has taken
scientists by surprise they're still
unsure of its source if there is a
hidden Reservoir perhaps a species that
transmits the virus but remains healthy
then it could become endemic and
impossible to control
Thomas More Sky News in Yorkshire